[MUSIC]
There's a lot of kind of discussion
of what the political beliefs of
Silicon Valley elites and founders are,
but we actually have no hard data on what
they actually believe when it
comes to politics and policy.
>> Some people say Silicon Valley is
really libertarian, other people say,
Silicon Valley, they're all just like
loyal democrats, Silicon Valley, they all
just care about the social issues and
they're very far left on social issues.
However, although there's no
a lot of thinking about, for
example, people on Wall Street,
how do they think about politics?
What do they want?
How do they interface with
the political system?
There'd be much less thinking about
that same question on the context of
Silicon Valley.
[MUSIC]
>> Technology elites are basically liberal
on every dimension you could think of
except regulation.
And this is actually really interesting
because there is no other group
of people that we surveyed, that have
this constellation of political beliefs.
And specifically when you come to economic
issues, they are not easily categorized as
libertarians, because they believe
in the redistribution of income, for
things like health care and
education and poverty reduction.
But at the same time,
they believe that government
should not be regulating business.
And some people have now called this new
type of political animal, the libertarian.
So they're trying to find new words and
terminologies, and so
it's been kind of interesting to see our
people try to Introducing new categories
to match the results we've been finding.
[MUSIC]
>> A lot of Silicon Valley companies right
now are innovating and labor markets.
Uber is a great example, where there's
a question of whether gig workers for
Uber should be treated like
regular workers or as contractors.
You can imagine labor unions see
that as a classic case where
it's important these workers
receive protections,
all the protections that would be
associated with traditional employees.
Whereas technology entrepreneurs
look at this and they say,
no, we shouldn't be regulating how
these companies treat workers,
we should give them freedom
in the marketplace.
And so that's a classic example where I
think in a lot of states that usually
starting to come do ahead and
you could imagine that is sort of thing
that those who were to protect companies
who were doing more donating in
democratic campaigns are going to say,
actually we disagree with the labor
unions that are endorsing you.
We think you should take this
other position on this issue.
So those kinds of tensions
within the democratic party,
we think they going to
become increasingly common.
[MUSIC]
>> A lot of historical research has found
that parties usually change when there's
important groups within those parties
that agree with them on most things, but
disagree with them on a few things, and
then they shape the party
in that direction.
So a classic example is that the AFL-CIO,
the CIO portion of it before it merged,
was very tolerant of racial progress.
And at the time,
the democrats had a lot of virulent
racist people as leaders in that party,
and they sort of used labor, which they
agreed with the Democratic Party on, and
shifted the Democratic Party to being
more of a ProCivil rights party.
And this pattern has emerged over and
over again in American history.
So one prediction our research suggests
is that, as technology leads become more
important part of the Democratic Party,
in terms of its fund raising apparatus,
they're going to double down and promote
traditional democratic interests when it
comes to social policy, redistribution,
foreign policy, immigration.
But try to move it towards the right
on issues when it comes to regulation,
particularly of labor markets.
[MUSIC]
I think a big question right now in
politics is the gap between elites and
masses.
And for the whole post World War period,
there's been sort of an agreement
that we would devolve some power to
elites who would then look out for
like everybody's interest.
But increasingly we've seen populist
revolts going on in the United States and
all the way across the world.
What people and the masses have kind
of realized are wages have stagnated,
expenses in real terms have gone up
on things like health insurance and
college tuition etcetera, and our children
are going to be living worse lives
with a worse standard
of living than we did.
And so there's a lot of discussion about
well, how does our democratic institutions
going to survive if there's not going to
be cooperation between masses and elites?
So I think a lot of this research has to
continue to explore this question more.
I think Dave and I are just generally
interested in kind of understanding, well,
who are the elites and what does
that mean and what do they believe?
And before we did a study like this,
there really was no data, and
it's because these are very hard people
to interview and get their opinions on.
And I think just future work
needs to be done in this topic so
we can understand the contours and
potential fault lines in politics,
both in the United States and abroad.
>> The other transformation you've seen
economically for a lot of Americans is not
only have we just stagnated, but
people are exposed to increasing risk.
And so a lot of the kind of government run
programs that technology entrepreneurs can
be more skeptical of.
They're not just about
transferring resources,
they're about some form
of social insurance.
And so I think as people
are exposed to more and more risk,
that might be an experience that
technology entrepreneurs haven't directly
experienced as much, and so that's another
gap that I'm interested in looking at.
>> I'm a big believer that I think social
science should be addressing questions
that are important to the broader world.
That if the world says,
these are the issues that are important
to how human beings are going to have
to grapple with their democracies,
their societies, then that's what
academics should be studying.
So that's one reason I was very proud
of this study, is that these issues of
inequality, automation, technology, this
is what the world is facing right now,
and so I think it's important to
address questions that are relevant.
[MUSIC]